[Musique]
avec l'arrivée du printemps on a envie
d'aller jouer dehors
et pourquoi ne pas en profiter pour
faire de la science comme nous le
raconte l'astronaute julie payette pas
besoin d'un doctorat pour faire avancer
la recherche
[Musique]
la pierre angulaire de toute recherche
c'est l'observation et la collecte de
données comme ça demande beaucoup de
temps de plus en plus de chercheurs font
appel au public pour faire progresser
leurs travaux c'est ce qu'on appelle la
science participative ou six ans
citoyenne que ce soit en astrophysique
en médecine ou en biologie
tout le monde est invité à donner un
coup de main pour faire avancer les
connaissances l'ornithologie est un bon
et ce depuis plus d'un siècle les
scientifiques utilisent les données
fournies par les amateurs d'oiseaux pour
augmenter rapidement leur
échantillonnage et faire des suivis à
long terme
certaines études durent d'ailleurs
depuis des décennies que ce soit pour
déterminer les dates de floraison des
plantes ou pour recueillir des données
météo l'idée de faire participer le
public à la démarche scientifique n'est
pas nouvelle mais avec les outils
informatiques disponibles aujourd'hui
c'est plus facile que jamais
sur le terrain un téléphone peut servir
à la fois d'appareils photos d'ouvragés
de référence le localisateur gps et bien
entendu d'outils pour partager les
données recueillies en recevant de
l'information d'un peu partout
les scientifiques multiplient leurs
capacités de recherche d'une façon qui
ne serait pas possible autrement
ils peuvent ensuite recouper ces données
avec d'autres observations comme celle
des satellites en orbite pour que les
données du public soit utilisable
il est important qu'elles soient
recueillies avec une certaine rigueur et
avec homogénéité qu'on soient experts ou
non dans un domaine il y a une méthode
une recette à suivre par exemple le
projet participatif appelée mission
monarque a pour objectif de mieux
comprendre pourquoi le nombre de ces
papillons décline depuis une vingtaine
d'années pour participer il faut se
familiariser avec leurs plantes favorite
l'asclépiade avoir l'oeil pour trouver
les oeufs les chenilles ou les
chrysalides et bien sûr prendre le tout
en haute avec un peu de formation et en
suivant le protocole c'est à la fois
utile et agréable
une autre façon de contribuer c'est de
faire le tri dans des données déjà
récolté et ça peut se faire n'importe où
même dans le confort de son salon un
site internet en particulier universe
héberge une multitude de projets qui ont
besoin de votre être
et il y en a pour tous les goûts par
exemple on vous demande de fouiller dans
les carnets de bord d' ancien navire
pour y trouver des renseignements sur
l'épaisseur des glaces ou sur le nombre
de baleines ou encore dans les photos
aériennes de l'amazone i pour étudier
les cycles de la végétation ou pour
caractériser les éruptions à la surface
du soleil ou des chiffres et les
rapports militaires de la première
guerre mondiale
si vous cherchez quelque chose d'autre
il y a même des jeux vidéo de science
participative qui exploite deux qualités
bien humaine notre raisonnement spatial
et notre esprit de compétition
[Musique]
un des jeux vidéo pionnier du genre
s'appelle food le jeu consiste à replier
la chaînes d'acides aminés des protéines
pour en découvrir leur structure en
trois dimensions
c'est une donnée essentielle car en
connaissant la structure d'une protéine
liée à une maladie on peut la cibler
plus efficacement avec des médicaments
les ordinateurs ont beaucoup de
difficultés avec ce genre de cas stade
iii b alors que les humains trouve la
solution
intuitivement
certains jeux ont des centaines de
milliers d'adeptes qui cartographie les
neurones de l'oeil ou aide à la
recherche sur le cancer
les joueurs peuvent même inventer de
nouvelles structures et les meilleures
idées sont testés en laboratoire comme
vous le voyez une contribution citoyenne
est une source précieuse d'information
pour les scientifiques observé le mot
l'analyse et le comprendre
c'est une aventure qui nous implique
tous de tout temps ce sont des gens
passionnés et curieux qui ont fait
avancer les connaissances et c'est
toujours le cas
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez en
faire partie la science participative
c'est amusant et c'est ouvert à tous et
si je lui paye plaisait si l'idée vous
intéresse je vous invite à consulter la
liste de projets que nous avons préparé
sur radio canada.ca barres obliques
participative